et contrôle routier aujourd'hui sur la
route nationale 186 vers saint germain
en laye sous réquisition du procureur de
la république
les policiers ont procédé à des
contrôles de véhicules ouverture de
coffre est permis de conduire un
contrôle routier particulier puisque la
direction départementale des services de
police du 78 étaient assistés d'une
délégation indienne composée de onze
responsables commissariats locaux une
opération destinée à présenter le
travail des agents français concernant
notamment la sécurité routière écouter
aujourd'hui enfin contrôle routier
relativement classique avec toutes les
réquisitions du procureur la république
de versailles qui nous autorise
notamment à ouvrir les coffres à
contrôler l'identité de toute personne
circulant sur le territoire sont le
secteur en tous les cas et nous faisons
ça au profit d'une délégation de
policiers indiens qui vient voir en
france comment on traite le problème de
l'insécurité routière
chez nous la police travaille sur les
mêmes situations nous avons les mêmes
problèmes
mais c'est le contexte qui est différent
ce que nous essayons de comprendre ici
c'est comment la technologie utilisée en
france pourrait être utilisé chez nous
en inde
ici nous avons plusieurs situations et
nous avons pu voir en application ces
équipements je suis certain que cela
sera utile pour nos équipes en inde de
réfléchir comment utiliser ces
équipements la chesnoye semaine